[Music]
hey
we're back yeah hopefully you guys
didn't miss us too much yesterday
hopefully you didn't fall asleep during
that last episode we did
i didn't hardly make it through that
[ __ ] i can't i can only remember the
first half
you did good second half i just it's
just all just a blur
it's too much [ __ ] drinking man
drinking twice a week now
that's not really normal for us man well
i don't know about that
it kind of is i actually kind of drink
less than i used to like in my 30s and
early 40s
i used to drink pretty much every night
i don't really do that much anymore
i hope it was a good show i think it was
good i don't
i don't remember anything going to a rye
the [ __ ] [ __ ] fell
three times it's in three pieces are you
gonna put it in one piece you're just
gonna let it ride like that
well it's too much of a pain
the audio version i i edited that all
together into one piece
all right but the video version like i
said it's too much of a pain to do i
don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
youtube
youtube's falling apart
all this shit's falling apart that's the
spirit
yeah it's apocalypse
he just wants it to be the apocalypse no
i'm just seeing it man
okay go ahead and you don't want me to
be negative but i just
i'm seeing this [ __ ] every day [ __ ]
make less and less sense
i like what they're doing on wall street
though just embrace the suck
you know everybody can see it for what
it is now
you know but yeah so uh sorry we didn't
do
a uh live stream yesterday but like i
said we
drove over to the wilds of ocala
yeah that was the [ __ ] there man [ __ ]
i haven't been out the country in a long
time
i always forget it's like you know i
used to go into my mom's house all the
time but it's like every time i go i
always forget and i say this every
single time i go out there i'm like holy
crap i always forget how far out in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere this place is
there's like nothing it takes an hour
and a half to get there from here
there's nothing on the way there [ __ ]
halfway
there was a a gas station yeah and that
was like that
that was like a gas station in like a
dollar general yeah and
that [ __ ] was the attraction for the
whole [ __ ] area
yeah it was [ __ ] packed there's
nothing else to do
it's like what the [ __ ] it was just
filled up to the brim
that's what people were waiting to buy
[ __ ] and buy gas and
it was like and i hadn't seen like
it's like your weekly excursion i hadn't
seen florida country people in a while i
forgot how [ __ ] big they were man
they're [ __ ]
walking there's like what's up little
man
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's real country half
them women
look like a [ __ ] stack of potato
sacks
i was just like god damn and what's
funny is that they have money man they
have [ __ ] expensive cars
harley davidson's [ __ ] everyone's got
big farms out there
harley-davidson it's all like rural i
must have saw 20 [ __ ] harleys man
nice bikes too and then a lot of those
dodge chargers
and [ __ ] anything that look like a
70s
muscle car they they have it they have
it and
uh it was wild man it was [ __ ]
trump's still president out there i tell
you man [ __ ] it all the flagpoles had
[ __ ] trump
flags on them and there were more
confederate flags and gadsden flags than
american flags out there
what did you say jenny or maybe half of
it yeah but like i said it's florida
it was no joke it's always been it was
[ __ ] no joke i forgot man
i forgot what it was like i said that's
out that's literally out in the middle
of
nowhere
you can go 30 40 miles and not see a
single other car
not see a single other there's a road
obviously there's all kinds of people
and houses out there
yeah there's houses but a lot of them
are kind of spread out every now and
then there'd be like a little
town yeah i don't even know if you'd
call it a town
sometimes you can see back inside the
woods with these little bitty houses
some cut half of them
half of them abandoned some look like
trailers some of them look like houses
and then it'll be a [ __ ] mansion
yeah it was like a big horse yeah like
corral like around it
yeah and it doesn't matter [ __ ] what
kind of house it is or trailer they have
those down four-wheelers
yeah and it's not a four-wheeler it's
like a
it's like something the army has now
it's it's kind of like a
a gator it's a four-wheeler is more like
a four-wheeled motorcycle these are like
little bitty cars
yeah yeah we saw a bunch of those lots
of those well the thing about it i mean
it's ocala national forest which
if you're not from here it's like it's
kind of in the middle of the state but
it's massive
obviously it's like a national park and
it's really really big and you can camp
there so there's every now and then
there's campgrounds or there's like a
little river or there's a spring
when i was a kid we used to go to
alexander springs
and silver glenn i think is another
spring there and like sometimes we would
go there and camp and there's like a
little
you know there's like a a really nice
spring and there's gators and stuff and
you can swim down in there you can scuba
dive and
snorkel and that kind of [ __ ] dude
canoeing i just did that
when i was a kid i forgot you know
because i lived on the eustis for a
little while i just forgot
how [ __ ] country folk around here
look
they're [ __ ] big man the women are
six feet tall
[Laughter]
you're watching arrows
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's like the [ __ ] local that's
like the local tourist trap
we were driving on the way back and i
was like jenny man i'd love to [ __ ]
put a restaurant out here
there was no restaurants hardly any that
was like i said there was a tiny little
shack that was like a barbecue place
and i think that there was a subway
attached to that gas station
yeah and that was about it i'd say i put
a country restaurant out here with
hamburgers and chicken fried steak
and you'd have to have like i'll give
out some [ __ ]
chicken curry and get them into that
foreign it's a really good pizza so
there's no pizza out there and just as i
said that we [ __ ] pass the pizza
there was one pizza place
i was thinking yeah where the [ __ ] do
you get a pizza around here yeah there's
no dominoes or nothing yeah
it's crazy you you forget how
remote some of this and it's not like i
said it's not super far it takes an hour
and a half
almost exactly to get from here which is
sanford to my mom's house
um but during that way there's a really
and my gps kept dropping out like my
[ __ ] cell phone signal keeps dropping
out you actually you can't usually get a
signal at my mom's house because it's
kind of out in the middle of nowhere
it's super creepy but it's like really
really quiet out there yeah we got lost
on the way there
it was some [ __ ] it was i thought i
thought i had stumbled into onto the
[ __ ] and you gotta understand
something i'm from mississippi the bills
have eyes [ __ ] yeah i thought i wasn't
like
i was like man this is some [ __ ]
chainsaw massacre [ __ ] going on here man
just dirt roads with big huge potholes
that lead to little [ __ ] cottages in
the middle of a [ __ ] thicket
and they're like man they have
electricity out here what the [ __ ]
and you could tell that they said [ __ ]
those potholes let them get bigger
those things were like three yeah
because those were some those people
they don't want you back
in there no they didn't want you back
yeah they're like not even potholes
these were like big
craters you could almost skateboard in
them
they just done that yeah although it was
like i'm sure they have to go places
sometime you think that would be like
too much of a pain in the ass like every
time they have to go to the [ __ ]
store for toilet paper they have to go
mess up your [ __ ] yeah but that was a
little that was a little you know
mississippi is a little flatter and it's
it's it's not quite
over as overgrown you know what i mean
you see the houses
you're going to trim your [ __ ] so you
can see the house those houses those
houses were hidden in those damn bushes
well like i said it's ocala national
forest yeah and around the outside they
sell lots and everything so yeah so
it's so it's a literal forest yeah it's
just it's a trip man hadn't been down
there in a while
and forgot how boring it would be yeah
yeah i mean there's not much going on
and what's funny is that where we live
you go just a few minutes you're like
you're downtown okay yeah but if you go
five minutes in the other direction
you're out in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere again yeah
i forgot about that yeah we're like
right on the right edge yeah
i mean we're only i never go that way
anymore we're only like two miles from
i-4
right which goes right downtown and it
takes about 20 minutes to get downtown
that's like 18 miles something like that
but yeah you go a few minutes in the
other direction and there's just like
hardly anything
it's just like farms and road and
nothingness
it's super crazy yeah and i always
forget every time we go out there
it was nice to see my mom my sister came
down that's why i went uh
out there we don't usually make that
horrible drive because it takes forever
we didn't get home until like 6 30 i
don't think and we weren't even there
that long
all right so i know one thing though i
wouldn't go out there and start [ __ ]
around
not with people they weren't [ __ ]
playing
no they weren't [ __ ] playing not at
all no
[Laughter]
they're just i don't know if you were
probably foreign
maybe if you're around from a big city
or from europe i don't think there's
anything like that in europe
not the concept that you could just get
on a damn vehicle
and get on and start driving through the
woods for a [ __ ] half hour and you're
still on the same dudes property
i don't think that really exists in
europe does it well i don't know don't
worry
but yeah if you ever got any trouble out
there then you're on your own you're on
your [ __ ] own
well all i could think while we were
driving i'm like wow it'd be really easy
to hide a body out here
they would never find it they would
never find it you wouldn't want to make
them natives [ __ ] angry
well they'll just feed just them
alligators man they'll just
throw you in lake oklahoma or whatever
i was impressed even from a mississippi
standpoint
i was like these [ __ ] are rough man
and they don't
and and here's the thing they have money
they have money they had money had good
vehicles
[ __ ] awk i imagine they had some
[ __ ] bad ass guns too
they knew what was up i mean like i said
some of the houses were real shitty but
yeah
some of them were actually really nice
you noticed some of them shitty old
houses also had [ __ ] bad ass hot rods
out in front well yeah that's where
that's where their priorities
[Laughter]
got my priorities straight yeah it's a
little scary out there yeah my mom's
lived out there for
goddamn since the 90s i think yeah and
then you'd see a [ __ ] mansion
yeah yeah it's really weird yeah um
so yeah let's uh talk a little bit about
this movie
so we watched this a couple nights ago i
remember somebody
asking us to review this because uh
shutter just added it somebody said no
tom you can't have a throne made out of
skulls
that'd be cool huh he's like that's it i
thought i was gonna see
i thought i was gonna see daryl and
merle at any [ __ ] moment
but yeah so somebody asked us to review
this movie this is called
the queen of black magic at least that
is the english title
now this is uh a shutter exclusive
and it was just added like a week or so
ago and
this is another indonesian movie
and it was written by um joko anwar
who's the same guy that wrote
in petagor which i actually really liked
one of my favorite horror movies of last
year
um so i i liked him pedigore more than
this one but this one was pretty good
too although i will say
this one reminded me a lot of what was
that other indonesian movie we just
reviewed um
i think it was may the devil take you or
may the devil take you there's been so
many of them
it had like a similar kind of story
excuse me
so i feel like that you know so a lot of
the indonesian movies particularly the
ones
you know that were written and directed
by the same dudes they have a similar
vibe to them so sometimes they do kind
of like blend together a little bit but
that said
i really liked this this one although i
will say i liked the first half better
than the second half
i for some reason i liked the first half
was like really creepy and moody and
unsettling and stuff and then
i think at the second half it went more
like straight on
horror and gore and stuff which was fine
but you know
it was not a bad movie i enjoyed it um
it was there's some about indonesia
they're kind of
they're they're they're they're doing
good right now at least the the movies
that we're getting here tonight in the
united states
wasn't the one about the alligator down
in the pool wasn't that indeed that was
a tie
that was tied that was the time movie
yeah the pool yeah the pool that was a
good one too i really like that
it was okay um it was
there was a lot of influence from
hollywood horror movies you could see
where you know
they were they were homage and a lot of
stuff uh
so you could tell the director and the
writer they you know they like horror
movies
and uh i'd imagine probably indonesia
watches a lot of the same classics that
you know we watch
well yeah horror fans around the world
just kind of oh i should
note too that this is actually a remake
of an indonesian film from 1981
so when it was gone i wasn't really sure
what it was i
thought maybe we were setting it up for
a haunted house type move or a
type movie it's a witch movie which it's
kind of like a haunted house pretty much
i mean you know that's
that's one thing is that it's called
queen of black magic so you know that
there has is gonna be some like witchery
afoot
like later on so the story about it is
that
there are these uh people
who grew up in an orphanage
and like it's kind of out in the middle
of nowhere and
i guess the dude that runs the orphanage
mr bandy i think his name is
um he's dying like he's on his deathbed
so all of these dudes
that are grown up now and they have
their own like wives and kids and
whatnot
so they're all kind of coming back to
this orphanage to
kind of pay their last respects to mr
bandy
so they get there and i really like this
is what i mean when i say like i really
like the beginning because i really like
they kind of you know just the opening
scene is just the family in the car
driving up there and they're just kind
of bantering back and forth like a
family it's you know it's very realistic
you get like a sense of their character
and whatnot it's like the dude his wife
and their three kids
and then it seems like they hit
something
um although you're led to believe that
maybe it's a deer but it's just kind of
like this
a little bit of an unsettling detail and
they're just like oh okay well there's
that happened and then they just get
there but then as it
progresses later on and i like that it's
kind of a slow burn to start with you
kind of get there all the other people
get there they all go see mr bandy who's
just laying there being like
like dying and whatnot and one of the
girls
who um i guess she works there or she's
one of the orphans
and she tells one of the kids about this
whole thing that supposedly happened
there was this woman
that used to live there or work there
and
she was presumed to have kidnapped
this other little girl that lived there
named marnie
and they never found marnie like she
went missing so they don't know if she
murdered her and buried her somewhere
or if she was abusing the girl and the
girl ran away or whatever so they never
found that
and so um they said so we you know
captured this woman and we
trapped her in this room and she ended
up dying from like banging her head
against the door and they think like
like she still haunts the [ __ ] and
everything so that was pretty cool like
i like that they
like you said that it had kind of almost
kind of like a 70s
yeah kind of vibe which like i said it's
it's a remake of a movie from 1981 so
maybe that's why
that it has that i could tell they were
trying to do that 70s kind of slow burn
set yeah in the beginning although it
once once once the magic started kicking
off it it
uh it didn't slow burn anymore it just
came on yeah there was just basically
centipedes flying and
people cutting off their own fat and you
know all kind of [ __ ]
it was an okay movie it was pretty good
i actually i actually really enjoyed it
um
like i said i think i maybe would give
impedigore the um
you know well a little bit more because
i think i like that a little bit more
if you're in if you're in the mood for
this kind of movie then you'd enjoy it
i'm not sure i was totally in the mood
for the time i was watching it
i think if i were to give a
recommendation for what you want to
watch tonight
wouldn't be this one it'd be one hour
photo with rob williams we just did a
review of that when we
saw that one again that [ __ ] is a
masterpiece yeah that's the that's
the one that's coming up on friday yeah
i think that was i think that was louis
that sent me that uh that
that blu-ray yeah it was louie i hope it
was because i think that's what we said
that's what we said on the tape louis
one night you just sent me that one-hour
photo yeah because he's here i don't
think michael is but
because i because i said you guys you
two are you know mainly as sophie does
too but you
you two guys are mainly the ones that
send us movies yeah so i knew it had to
be one of y'all
but yeah so but i really like i mean
this had some really cool imagery like i
said i liked
the beginning when i wasn't really sure
what was going on like with the whole
you know did i really hit a deer or did
i hit something else and then like they
go out in the [ __ ] corn field and
they find the bus
which i don't really want to spoil too
much of that but they find a bus out in
the corn field and
um yeah there's some like pretty creepy
[ __ ] in there like some kind of
horrifying
and so so i liked that because i was
just kind of like what the hell
was going on it wasn't louis the senate
we don't know who said it oh well [ __ ]
okay well
maybe it was michael then michael e i
don't know might have been because he
sends us a lot somebody said it to me
yeah we just we yeah we got it a few
weeks ago yeah if you guys haven't seen
one hour photo with
williams check that one out we've got
the review coming out in a couple days
you haven't seen it i don't want to
spoil it for you
but uh you could probably stream that
for a couple bucks
but uh that one's that's an excellent
watch
it's kind of very kubricky and
the visuals are [ __ ] great real good
story
um character driven [ __ ] robin
williams playing like a like a villain
sorta yeah sort of yeah he's mentally
ill
but you just got to see it's good real
good yeah so like i said it was you know
that's that's the uh movie retrospective
that we recorded for this week because
that was the one that won in the
poll but um but yeah if you have shutter
this is definitely worth watching
especially if you're into other
indonesian horror if you like satan
slaves or
you know pedigore or whatever yeah you
can get shutter without amazon yeah
because we had shutter way before we had
amazon prime it's a shutter speed yeah
it's a completely
um just a la carte service you just go
yeah i think it's it's 499 or 599 or
something like that
i usually get it because it's the best
buy on
on the internet yeah and actually if you
pay for it annually it's cheaper and i
got a free t-shirt i don't know if
they're still doing that i think it was
50
something a year to get his t-shirt i
think yeah i got like a t-shirt out of
it
um but yeah it's totally worth what i
mean there's always something on there
worth watching because they don't just
have movies they have
um they have series they have
a couple of like podcasts that you
listed they got some documentaries
they're always switching things out you
know what i mean it's not like a massive
massive library but it's really well
curated like they always
and they have like a really good mix of
new [ __ ] and old [ __ ] yeah
and stuff and got a lot of the old
classic 70s giallo movies and
yeah they have a [ __ ] ton of jell-o
movies yeah that were great that are
kind of forgotten you don't hear about
them
much anymore they're really well done
yeah you know i think i keep seeing dead
and buried coming up over and over again
every time
that's always on their little streaming
yeah that's a really good one
that's another thing too they have a
little streaming so so it's like you can
just
if you don't feel like picking something
you can just have it on it's just like
tv and then you just have it
it has it but it has like joe bob briggs
is on there like all his stuff
they have um channel zero which i really
like uh
a discovery of witches which i heard was
really good that's a series creep show
series
the creep show series like all that
stuff is on there like i said
documentaries all kind of stuff
so you know there's all kind of fun
stuff so i always do recommend it
because it's super cheap i mean it's one
of the cheapest
um services out there and especially if
you're
really into horror and you know you want
to see a lot of the new [ __ ]
there's always something good there's
always something worth watching on there
and like i said they're not endorsing
the channel or anything like that
i just really really like it but yeah
you can totally get it just
just by itself like standalone because
i've had it stand alone for a really
long time
um so what else we don't really have
anything else to
talk about do we probably not so uh i
guess we'll be finding
a newish movie this evening tattoo know
i
found one so i don't know what i'm going
to be watching yet but t's in there hey
t
go check out um one hour photo
see that one if you haven't seen it
pound says shutter is fine i wish it
would have had more of the universal
classics
i always kind of wonder if maybe maybe
copyright yeah maybe it's like harder
for them to get the rights they do have
a lot of
um hammer stuff they have a lot of
um like roger corman's like edgar allan
poe adaptations they have a bunch of
those but
yeah they don't seem to have a lot of
universal and like i said maybe it's
just kind of a thing where
they can't like they probably got
purchased by somebody who has a
streaming service
that's probably that's probably what it
is but i mean i've always been really
pleased with how
diverse their stuff is and they always
kind of come up with
like a lot of really good particularly
foreign stuff and old stuff that you
kind of forgot about you know what i
mean i'm just gonna bait
um universals is owned by disney now
um didn't did disney buy a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't know i feel like probably
one company owns everything nowadays so
yeah
yeah everything's and it's probably
obvious now that everything is a
monopoly
but that might be why that um that you
can't
that they can't get the universal stuff
i'm sure it's a rights issue but uh yeah
so
anyway i'm gonna find a new movie
tonight to watch and we'll talk about
that with you guys tomorrow
so thanks as always for dropping by
and uh we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow bye